- This is like the most romantic thing
we've done together.
(mumbles)
Mmm.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- The most wonderful
aspect of Bohri dining
is that we sit on the floor.
We have this big steel
plate called a thaal,
which we place on a
slightly elevated surface
and everyone sits around this thaal
and they all eat from the same plate.
- I am really scared looking
at the size of this thaali.
It's massive.
- It's gonna be pretty wholesome.
It's gonna be very difficult
to finish one dish,
is what I feel.
- Are there any rules to eating?
Like, is this my mine--
- Yeah, this is my space.
- Say for example, I like some meal--
- No, no.
(laughs)
- No, that's not happening.
- You're not coming here.
- No.
- We're gonna start
this off with something
called (mumbles) which is normally done
by the youngest person.
- The baby.
- In the group.
- Basically you're just
supposed to hold the salt
and it's used to clean the palate before
you start your meal, so--
- And activate your taste buds.
- Activate them. (mumbles)
- Samosas that are filled with kheema.
- Meat just makes everything better.
- I'm sorry, but it's a little bland.
- It's smoky. I can feel it smoky.
- It's just a regular samosa to me.
(grunts)
Just with meat.
- I feel I'm not gonna
be going back to other
samosas after this.
- This is sweet.
Apparently, if you alternate
between salty and sweet
it reactivates your palate.
- I really like this concept--
- Oh, my god.
- Of dessert in between meals.
- Okay, is that saffron?
Normally it has a very strong taste but--
- Overpowering, but it's not the case.
- I feel like I'm gonna
be bartering spoons
all together by the
end of this experience.
- No, I--
- This is the kind of
a dish that if no one
was looking, I would take like that--
- And just give up.
- And just go like all over.
- Where's my-- Oh my, guys.
(jeering)
Oh yeah.
- Guys, let's do this.
- I just don't want to look at you on--
- Don't.
- [Voiceover] The entire leg of the lamb.
- Oh, god.
- Oh my god.
- Holy shit.
- It comes right off.
- This is totally worth the
(mumbles) tablets I'm gonna
be having after this.
- You can't enjoy this with-- (mumbles)
- Pretty spicy.
- I love the spice.
- This is like an orgasm right off.
- [Voiceover] This is bhuna gosht.
- It's like the-- (mumbles)
- Fuck off, it's really good.
- This is more familiar to what we eat.
- Yeah.
- Generally.
- There are demarcation margins that we
aren't crossing over here.
- You better have nothing
to do for the rest
of the day if you plan on having gosht.
- Rest of the week.
- I've never had bread
and rice in the same meal.
(grunting)
I haven't done it.
- I think if I had pig done
so much in the previous course
and everyone--
- Exactly.
- Enjoy this moment.
- Completely discovering
the fact we're all
falling asleep slowly. (chuckles)
- You remember that scene where Joy
comes to eat their turkey wearing that
Madonna t-shirt?
- Yeah, that's basically--
(mumbles)
- So we just got done with what has been
the best meal of my life by
far in the past one year.
- It was a nice experience when everybody
like sitting together
and eating and sharing
the same plate.
- We all got forced.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- You know, I was really
uncomfortable first.
- I never shy away from
meat but right now,
I can't bear to look at lamb in the face.
- That was too much.
- My world is just happy
but confused and full.
- I didn't even know that
Bohri food was different
or had a style of its own.
- It just goes to show,
how much of a cultural
difference there is, like within our own
friend circle which we don't know about.
- That we don't talk about.